Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os hemos contado
en alguna que otra ocasión que vivimos en
un mundo que cada día es mejor.
Un mundo, amigos, en el que cada vez hay menos
pobreza y cada vez se vive mejor.
Un cambio que está llegando incluso a la región más
desamparada, al África Subsahariana.
En VisualPolitik ya os hemos hablado de los
leones africanos, y hemos prestado especial
atención a casos como el de Botswana o Ruanda.
Sin embargo, nos faltaba contar cuándo y
por qué comenzó todo este cambio en una
región del mundo que muchos consideraban
perdida y condenada.
Pues bien, amigos, eso es, precisamente, de
lo que vamos a hablar en este vídeo, de eso
y también de lo que podemos esperar en los
próximos años.
Durante años hablar de África ha sido hablar
de pobreza extrema, catástrofes naturales
y todo tipo de conflictos.
Y en cierto modo las cosas continúan así.
Fijaos, en la región del África subsahariana
viven ni más ni menos que la mitad, ojo,
la mitad de todas las personas que sufren
la pobreza extrema en el mundo.
Hablamos de casi 400 millones de personas.
Luego, noticias así tampoco nos sorprenden:
(“El mundo vive la mayor crisis humanitaria
desde 1945. La ONU alerta de que 20 millones
de personas en Sudán, Yemen, Nigeria y Somalia
están en situación de hambruna o en riesgo
inminente de caer en ella”. El Mundo)
Por todo esto, estoy seguro de que a ninguno
nos extraña encontrarnos cada dos por tres
con campañas de ONGs que buscan recaudar
fondos para hacer frente a todo tipo de catástrofes
humanitarias en África.
O que los gobiernos destinen miles de millones
de dólares cada año en Ayuda Oficial al  Desarrollo.
De hecho, amigos, la ayuda de los gobiernos
es la más grande de todas: cada año van
a parar al continente africano, atentos, unos
50.000 millones de dólares.
Y esto lleva siendo así desde hace... décadas.
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que durante años
todo esta cantidad de dinero no sirvió de mucho.
Echemos un vistazo, por ejemplo, a la década
de los 90.
Mientras la ayuda internacional
a esta zona del mundo sumaba decenas y decenas
de miles de millones…
¿Qué pensáis que ocurrió con la pobreza?
¿Creéis que se redujo? Pues… no, nada de eso.
(Entre 1990 y 1998 la pobreza no paró de
subir y pasó del 55% al 58%. Cada vez el
porcentaje de la población condenada a vivir
en la extrema pobreza era mayor).
Pero ¿cómo es esto posible? Pues… porque
una cosa son las intenciones y otra… la
realidad. Algunos expertos afirman que durante
años las ayudas oficiales debilitaron a los
productores locales.
“Las pruebas demuestran abrumadoramente
que la ayuda a África ha hecho que los pobres
sean más pobres y que el crecimiento sea
más lento.” Dambisa Moyo, economista nacida
en Zambia y autora de la obra la “Ayuda
que mata”.
Por ejemplo, en Tanzania era más barato comprar la leche subvencionada de la UE
que la de los productores locales.
Sin embargo, amigos, con el comienzo del nuevo
siglo, de repente todo empezó a cambiar….
EL GRAN CAMBIO
De repente, cuando África parecía no tener
remedio, todo empezó a cambiar.
Con el comienzo del siglo XXI las estadísticas
se dieron la vuelta...
Desde el año 2000 la pobreza extrema ha caído
casi un 40%; la esperanza media de vida ha
crecido en más de 10 años; la mortalidad
infantil se ha reducido a menos de la mitad;
lo mismo ocurrió con las infecciones de VIH
en niños y prácticamente con cualquier otra estadística.
Si nos fijamos en la economía, vemos como
entre el año 2000 y el año 2015 las economías
del África Sub Sahariana, excluyendo a Sudáfrica
- que es un caso, como vimos aquí en VisualPolitik,
un poco particular - crecieron de media por
encima, atentos, del 6%, más del doble, por
ejemplo, que Latinoamérica.
Otra indicador para ver cómo están cambiado
realmente las cosas lo encontramos en el turismo.
(El sector turístico tiene algunas características
particulares que nos revelan mucha información,
Por un lado, el turismo tiene un gran poder
de transformación para los más pobres gracias
a que es muy intensivo en mano de obra; y
por otro lado tenemos que tener en cuenta
que la gente no se va de vacaciones a países
en guerras, con hambrunas o epidemias. Cuando
el turismo mejora en los países más pobres,
suele ser un buen indicador de que las cosas
están mejorando)
Pues bien, si vamos a los datos es posible
que nos llevemos una sorpresa, porque este
sector, amigos, lleva 20 años, dos décadas
completas, creciendo a una tasa media anual,
ni más ni menos, que del 9%.
Sí, parece que las cosas empiezan a marchar.
Pero llegados a este punto, es muy posible
que os estéis haciendo una pregunta, yo desde
luego me la hago
¿Qué diantres pasó para que se produjera
semejante cambio?
Atentos a este gráfico, me parece que nos
da alguna pista:
Pero, insisto, ¿qué fue exactamente lo que
logró esta especie de “milagro”? Veámoslo.
PREPARANDO EL DESPEGUE
En los cambios son muchas las cosas que influyen,
pero vamos a ver cómo en África se produjeron
tres hechos que empezaron a cambiar, y creo
que para siempre, la realidad de este continente.
El primero, de todos, las remesas. Veréis,
en África la población crece muy rápido,
lo que unido a las pésimas condiciones de
vida, ha hecho que en las últimas décadas
muchos africanos hayan emigrado a países
más ricos.
(Hoy, estas personas, envían cada año decenas
de miles de millones de dólares a casa. Dinero
que se utiliza en los mercados locales o para
montar negocios, por ejemplo. Son las remesas,
y ojo, son mucho más importantes que la ayuda
al desarrollo).
¿Puede ser que la inmigración sea una política
solidaria? Pues… eso parece.
Segundo, muy importante. Marzo del año 2000,
el Congreso de Estados Unidos aprueba finalmente
una ley que había sido impulsado por Bill
Clinton en los últimos años de su mandato:
es la “African growth and Opportunity act”.
Básicamente una ley que establece un acuerdo
de comercio preferencial que elimina los aranceles
y reduce las trabas al comercio para miles
y miles de productos procedentes
del África Subsahariana.
(Desde que fue aprobado este acuerdo, vemos
como entre el año 2000 y el año 2016 - qué
no fue precisamente bueno - el comercio entre
Estados Unidos y el África Subsahariana se
ha multiplicado por 2,5, lo que supone un
crecimiento del 6% cada año).
Y tercero, tal vez la clave de todo: China.
Sí, tal cual como me escucháis.
En el año 2001 China accedió a la Organización
Mundial del Comercio y se convirtió en algo
así como “la fábrica del mundo”.
Pues bien, lo que ha ocurrido desde entonces
ha sido impresionante: el enorme crecimiento
de China ha sacado a decenas y decenas  de millones de personas de la pobreza… en China pero también
en África.
Me explico, el enorme crecimiento del gigante
asiático ha hecho que este país demande
todo tipo de productos: materias primas, alimentos,
manufacturas… ¡de todo!
(Muchos países africanos han aprovechado
para sumarse al carro. Desde el año 2000
el comercio entre China y África se ha multiplicado
ni más ni menos que por 17, lo que supone
un crecimiento anual de casi el 20%. Desde
el año 2009, China es ya con diferencia el
mayor socio comercial del continente).
Pero no solo eso, los chinos, lo sabéis,
lo hemos contado aquí, también están invirtiendo
mucho dinero por todo el mundo. Y África
no es una excepción.
En 2016, 4 de cada 10 euros que los extranjeros
invirtieron en África procedieron de China.
Hoy hay más de 10.000 empresas de este país
haciendo negocios en el continente africano,
empresas mayoritariamente privadas y que se
dedican a todo tipo de negocios.
Y, ojo, porque el número no hace más que
subir.
Sí, amigos, así es como África ha conseguido
empezar a dar la vuelta a las estadísticas.
El gran protagonista de todo este cambio,
no fue ningún tipo de milagro supraterrenal
ni tampoco tuvo mucho que ver la ayuda al
desarrollo.
El cambio lo produjo el comercio y la inversión.
Y ojo, Los propios africanos parecen tenerlo
muy claro ¿No me creeis? Pues.. fijaos:
“Los países africanos están avanzando
para completar las negociaciones para una
zona continental de libre comercio entre 55
países a principios del próximo año. La
idea, adoptada por la Unión Africana en 2012,
es crear un mercado único que incluya la
libre circulación de bienes, servicios y
personas.” CNBC
Sí, así es, en África están trabajando
para llevar el comercio a cada rincón del continente.
Ahora bien, es evidente que no todos los países
están desarrollándose por igual, pero esto
es algo normal, ya lo hemos visto en el pasado
en otras zonas del mundo.
SIGUIENDO LA ESTELA DE ASIA
Llegados a este punto, hay una pregunta que
creo debemos hacernos ¿Realmente podemos
soñar con el despegue definitivo de África?
Mirad, creo que muchos de vosotros estáis
pensando: bueno todo esto que me cuentan en
VisualPolitik es muy bonito… pero no es
algo generalizado.
Seguro que en África hay países a los que
les va bien y otros a los que no les va tan bien.
Pues ¿sabéis qué? Esto es verdad, pero también
es… normal.
Fijaos, hoy puede resultar chocante pero en
los años 50, Asia era tan pobre como África.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Sí, lo se, viendo ciudades como Shanghai,
Hong Kong o Taipei es muy difícil pensar
que hace no tantos años eran tan pobres.
Pero, mirad, cuando Corea del Sur o Taiwan
comenzaron a crecer, no eran países más
ricos que Ghana o Senegal, por ejemplo. Y
China, la India o Vietnam eran, desde luego,
bastante más pobres.
¡Cómo han cambiado las cosas!
Pues de todo esto podemos extraer alguna que
otra idea:
Amigos, los países asiáticos tampoco crecieron
todos de golpe, para nada.
Mientras Corea, Singapur, Japón o Taiwan, despegaban,
otros países como China, Indonesia o la India
permanecían sumidos en la pobreza.
Y luego, tampoco fueron precisamente modelos
democráticos, Corea del Sur o Taiwan fueron
duras dictaduras hasta practicamente antes
de ayer, Singapur ahí está… y sobre China..
que os voy a contar…
Resumiendo, mucha pobreza, unos países más
adelantados y otros más retrasados, dictaduras…
en fin, me parece que lo que vemos hoy en
África no es tan distinto a lo que hace 50
años ocurría en Asia.
¿LISTOS PARA DESPEGAR?
Sí, las cosas en África están cambiando.
De los 10 países que, aparentemente, más
están creciendo en 2017, 5 están aquí,
en África.
Si echamos un vistazo al último Doing Business,
el indicador del Banco Mundial que mide la
facilidad para hacer negocios, vemos como
de los 10 países que más han mejorado 4
son, también, africanos.
Es verdad, la pobreza sigue siendo muy alta,
y estos países se enfrentan a un reto difícil:
hacer frente a un crecimiento demográfico
tan grande que va a multiplicar la población
del continente en las próximas décadas.
Sin embargo, amigos, la buena noticia es que
todo apunta a que gracias al comercio y a
la inversión internacional, África está
encontrando su camino y puede estar, de una
vez por todas, apunto de despegar.
Pero ahora turno para ti ¿Crees que África
emulará el desarrollo que ha tenido Asia
en las últimas décadas?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo,
dale a like y no olvides suscribirte porque
vamos a sacar muchos más vídeos.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.